[Music]
you hosted the Fashion Awards yes this
is just very recently how long ago was
this it's like two weeks ten weeks ago
and you wore a well-known Marc Jacobs
outfit this photo was everywhere yes so
this is the outfit Marc gee Marc Jacobs
wore this outfit to the Metropolitan
ball yeah I feel like I wish I could
prove that someone else wore it before
you showed the picture right but Marc
Jacobs had worn this outfit and then
it's completely see-through and it's
completely see-through I'm wearing
boxers and you can't tell but my shoes
have buckles on them yeah and that makes
it all okay somehow yeah actually I'm
happy my hands make me feel like all
okay because I'm like this is dumb but
it was funny cuz Anna Wintour the editor
of Vogue I agreed to host these Fashion
Awards and Anna Wintour said to me she's
like I have the funniest idea and I had
this moment like oh do you and a Wintour
have the funniest idea right she was
like yeah you should wear Marc Jacobs
meta outfit I was like oh it's a pretty
funny guy yeah yeah like you were right
Anna Wintour didn't work for the whole
evening wasn't one of those things I
work for like one segment of the show
but I will say I pulled it on and I was
like oh that's gonna be awful and I put
it on and I was like this is the nicest
thing I've ever worn if any other
segment of my life it was cool to wear
this outfit I would wear this everywhere
I would wear it doing Weekend Update it
was so comfortable it was so breezy
[Laughter]
everything felt right yeah I did wear
two pairs of Underpants yeah I guess
very important just want to be careful
yeah yeah you don't want things bouncing
around
or you might I don't know